das für ein monster bist du noch ein
kranker kinder seit grauer
rösler münchen verschlug metzger felser
ein guter riesen das zunächst mal ein
großes spektakel
unglaublich die tricktechnik wenn man
riesen auf die leinwand bringt dann
macht man das heutzutage natürlich durch
mensch viel computer manipulation und
ähnliche dinge und wenn man das einmal
erkannt hat dass da tatsächlich ein
unglaublich ernst zu nehmender
schauspieler ein denkbar computer
manipulierte figur spielt dann hat man
wirklich spaß an dem was passierte dann
fängt man auch an auf die anderen riesen
zu achten und dann wirklich und
ansonsten was geschieht es wird ein
kleines mädchen von einem riesen in
london entführt und das ganze klingt
erstmal sehr bedrohlich aber man muss
sagen das riesaer riese nicht ganz
zufällig auch den namen big friendly
giant von dem mädchen verliehen bekommt
das ist ein denkbar freundliches wesen
und das ist ein riese der träume von
kindern einsammelt
wir müssen das kann uns leicht fiel kopf
und magen kosten klein meister der
tarnung das ist schon beispiel im buch
von dahl ein gewisses motiv denn da wird
erzählt wie großartig der sich durch
london schleicht und zwieback zeigt dass
mit eben ganz simplen fast schon
theatermittel das ist die schwäche des
films die geschichte an für sich ist
schlicht wie es ein gutes kinderbuch
überhaupt nicht negativ zu werten wäre
aber für 120 minuten film dies nun doch
am ende geworden sind hätte man sich
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr
konzentration gewünscht oder man hätte
das drehbuch wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
darüber hinaus ausweiten müssen was ihn
da als buch drin ist für die ich jetzt
tut viel der sicherste platz verdient
was zunehmender weise ein echter
fehlgriff ist das große finale
da wird eben ein einsatz der britischen
armee gegen die riesen gezeigt und der
läuft wirklich abwegig invasion im irak
mit hubschraubern und risiken militär
massen wieder einmarschieren
wir haben all diese bilder der letzten
jahrzehnte mit kriegseinsatz moderne art
im kopf und da vergreift sich spielberg
finde ich unglaublich im bild da kann
man mit der ganzen familie rein gehen
das ist überhaupt kein problem es wird
sowohl für kleine kinder einiges geboten
wobei man natürlich sehen muss dass die
unmittelbare bedrohung durch die großen
riesen mit schon etwas ist wo ich jetzt
behaupten würde ersparen sie es mal
läuten die jünger als sieben sie halt
die luft an quetscht die daumen und los
geht's